para determinar la responsabilidad de
una crisis sanitaria que sitúa brasil
cada vez más cerca de las 400.000
muertes comenzó una investigación en el
senado que determinará las posibles
omisiones del presidente ya ir bolsonaro
ante la pandemia de kobe 19
nuestro objetivo no es sólo buscar
responsables y culpables sino que todo
el cpi haga propuestas para que podamos
implementar para saber qué está pasando
la investigación que durará 90 días se
centrará en más de 20 causas como la
presunta negligencia en la compra de
vacunas y la politización de la pandemia
las pesquisas podrían dificultar los
planes de bolsonaro para presentarse a
la reelección en 2022 ya que el
ultraderechista se ha caracterizado por
su negacionismo respecto al virus
cuestionó la eficacia de tapabocas y
recomendó el uso de remedios no probados
científicamente entre otros polémicos
comentarios
no estoy preocupado por el pp y no estoy
preocupado porque no debemos nada la
comisión está controlada por la
oposición ya que sólo cuatro de sus once
miembros son favorables al mando
por lo que el hijo del presidente sensor
flavio bolsonaro cuestionó su
parcialidad es la única persona que ya
anticipó alguna decisión sobre la
investigación fue el propio senador
renán calheiros quien concedió una
entrevista diciendo de manera apresurada
ya prejuzgando que se mantuvo callado e
incompetente en el tiempo político
a pesar de la situación epidemiológica
crítica el gigante sudamericano está
registrando una ligera desaceleración de
casos tras dejar atrás los 4 meses más
mortíferos de la pandemia y por primera
vez desde noviembre la tasa de contagios
en brasil es menor al 1